so bunch of microwave dad I asked why it
blocks UHF frequencies before we get on
to the stories I need to know more about
you I'm 29 years old I work as a product
contractor for the NSA for the CIA I
worked in various jobs in the
intelligence industry for the last nine
years wasn't they're gonna come from and
now that we've made contact they're
gonna come for all teach how about we
just start with your name ok my name is
edward joseph Snowden
sooo
what was it you were doing doing
analysis for those stage partner don't
be shy I don't want anyone else the
modern battlefield is everywhere how is
this all possible I think of it as a
google search except instead of
searching only what people make public
we're also looking at everything they
don't I know about you conversations
what is this leave that there are they
watching us the house is boat
one man can stop the motor of the world
what was it about this job that makes it
warm prank in your life
Snowden has been charged with espionage
you have no idea what it's like to be
accountable for other people's lives
are you going away everything I have
they're gonna figure out what I've done
did you access an unauthorized throne
run the government knows that we have
these documents now